the other day target on their
international website leaked middle
Earth's shadow of war which we've kind
of known the sequels in the works for
shadow of mordor the 2014 game for a
while I mean it wasn't it was like
people suspected if it was nothing
confirmed so now target accidentally
leaked it and then yesterday I believe
Warner Bros but yeah this is an official
thing we came in the morning they said
yeah middle-earth shadow of war is the
thing they showed the trailer off I
guess like to coincide with GCC this
week in San Francisco and it looks
pretty cool I don't you're not a Tolkien
fan Kelly I don't you Pete you're not
super into spoken stuff I read the books
of the kid look I like the movies
through degree of it no not hardcore you
dabbled in the game right in 2014 shadow
and what are back being generous yeah
yeah yeah I know very little about
Laurel rings okay it was my favorite
game 2014 so I wanted to talk about kind
of what to expect or what we want in
shadow of war like what do you want and
share what do I want so I think the
thing that the game is most known for
the first game is the Nemesis system
which is sure you know I haven't played
game you're still probably familiar with
it it was great at the time it's cool
they're still it was you know you fight
this one orc leader and depending on how
you kill him he'll he could come back
later and have like a grudge against you
or beef with another orc leader and you
can kind of pick them against each other
in this open world and it actually felt
like you were kind of molding things
depending on your actions so now they're
saying you're actually going to shape
the world that could be just like you go
the marketing broad statement or abroad
and kind of bold I guess maybe not bold
but how are we actually going to shape
this world is when I'm wondering they
say there's a new stronghold system so i
wonder if like the factions will be
affected more from how you take down
specific outposts and whatnot because
that's a big part right you're just
rating your Italian and you're going
around Mordor with Kelly brim bore here
he's a race now but he's originally else
who crafted her helped craft the
original ring of power but in this
trailer it shows that you are you know
like talion kelabra more were kind of
fused and he's now part race part undead
Ranger after having died in the first
game which is not really smaller what
happens right at the beginning and you
know sauron's back this whole trailer
showing Sauron for those who don't know
he's a dark or he's
dude and he's a lava and that massive
helmet isn't telling you but so you're
crafting your own ring of power to rival
him it looks awesome I loved the first
game more than I can explain I don't
want to get into that jar a different
segment maybe but I am really I what I
want is for the world actually to react
to me like they're saying it is but I
want the stronghold to kind of change
based on what i do at each one not just
the Nemesis system I want that to be
somehow factored into the world because
it was really impressive how that worked
in the first game you know you get those
you get that little like a checkerboard
of Orcs it shows us like a experience
tree almost but with like the orc
leaders and you know depending on how
you kill this one that'll affect this
one status and you essentially are like
pushing this one guy up to the top so
you can assassinate him and take out the
faction it was great and I actually I
want that to work with the stronghold
you know not just the enemies um so of
your brief time would the first game
like what do you play like an hour or
two yeah did you like the open world at
all I mean a little I saw of it yes
mobility is something that I like really
highly valuing games and I remember
correctly the character is pretty good
at like scaling walls and being kind of
like stealthy and sneaking around and
covering ground and stuff so that's not
really good like the movement felt great
and watching other people play it looked
like you definitely unlock a lot of
powers that make you more sweat and then
lethal so I found like things that were
interesting to me but it was just at a
point in time right I didn't wasn't
ready to play game you know because of
assignments or whatever the mobility was
great there was just one movie unlock
later on where you land and then you tap
a button and he does this dash so you
could fast travel but you felt kind of
too good it was almost like how it goes
like sunset overdrive or something but I
didn't want a fast travel because it
felt so good to move around right and
the stealth mechanics worked the stealth
in the combat were kind of you know like
to name the game that started this trend
it was the Arkham Asylum combat right
the attack encounter system with a few
other things thrown in but the you know
the dichotomy between the Wraith attacks
and the Ranger attacks is where
really drove this game i think aside
from the Nemesis system which was the
drawing factor and i want to see more of
that especially now the of your own ring
of power I want to just be able to be
completely overpowered at the end of the
game because even at the end of shadow
of mordor into them 14 I didn't ever
feel overpowered at the end because
these orcs were becoming so good the
Nemet a loon they scale to you yeah and
I actually kind of want I want them to
make me feel like I actually have a ring
of power I don't want it to be just this
narrative device I wanted to be this
thing fueling my abilities right because
it used to be just Ranger abilities or
race abilities and now I actually want
to just be like blowing the [ __ ] up
people essentially you just want to blow
a bunch people you just load of [ __ ] out
of people it's still not a good you're
going to chat let me know if what you
want to see in shadow of war you meant
blow up yes I have a question so my not
about that Satya both of you I like to
joke that my extent a the extent of my
lord of the rings knowledge as the
several Led Zeppelin songs about Laurel
rings oh yeah so yeah um in a part 1
yeah ramble on etc etc so thank you so
my question is what like should I even
care if I don't know anything about Lord
of the Rings like what's the draw there
for like you're a super fan what's the
draw there for me um I see well I don't
know whether you could jump in with this
game you could jump into lord the rings
with shadow of mordor you can get shadow
Mordor without needing to worry about
talking back story they do a really good
job of using tokens world as you know
backstory but having a really good
self-contained story in itself I did it
canon or is it not canon it's canon they
use the actual events aren't candid but
they usually the hell of a boiler
character the elf Caliburn boards a real
character he like helped forge the Ring
of Power but I don't believe these games
a cannon and I could be completely wrong
but from playing through that thing of
43 years ago who do I anymore yeah I
mean one right talking son so all having
kind of controls like the publishing and
like all of that they're super strict
it's actually crazy how close to
not being made shadow of mordor was
because of how strict the Tolkien estate
is with everything Oh sidewinder 2057
does not care shadow of who give a [ __ ]
it's not canon Thank You apex penguin I
I didn't think but they are using real
character Killebrew more is a real
character so it's so the the floor
itself the backdrop is is all in line
with ok that's basically right so yes to
answer your question I think you could
easily are you asking if you could just
jump in with shadow Mordor to get ready
for this yeah yeah you don't need
extended totally Noah is in shadow of
mordor for someone like me who doesn't
who don't want to listen to Led Zeppelin
all day I turn that on why you play
probably be a fun in time but yeah like
I i think the open world itself you I
thought it'd be boring right these muted
colors but then there's another part of
it later on it's pretty lush Mordor
despite the fact that you think of all
this so you know volcanic igneous rawr
their big spiders yeah I believe so are
there trees that walk I don't think
there are end no are there is there a
guy who talks himself in the case golem
yes yeah isn't it I'm really
exaggerating how little I know I know
that his name was come to calling yeah
yeah they mentioned gone since ramble on
would you say that you want shadow war
to kind of just build on shadow mode or
without making you feel excluded for not
knowing much about Tolkien yeah like I
guess my big concerns like hearing you
talk about how much you love this game
like I want to give it a shot I'm
worried that i will be too basic for it
yeah I know it I love the game for
reasons completely separate from my
Tolkien fandom uh we don't have a
lecturer a career here anymore she was
the Tolkien like genius here at gamespot
before she went on to new projects but
she was also always the one talking
about how this game did a great job of
like I said having its own
self-contained story within tokens world
but you know not necessarily pushing you
away if you don't care about talking I
like the game for reasons apart from
that I love the game for the Nemesis
system how it reacts to you I hope in
shadow of war that they actually make
good on that promise to you know kind of
the world being shaped yeah at your hand
a lot of games say they're going to do
that but we'll see if shadow of war
actually does
in August not crazy far away supercell
yeah where we know it yeah well
especially because everything leading
out to those crazy like through March we
have a lot of releases especially the
Nintendo switched launching which are
going to get to for those of you who
were open world games are coming see I
don't know we because last year was
actually kind of sparse for immoral
games for once and and that you're
talking about no no no compared to like
years before that yet last year there
was like five which is not much being
the person who reviewed most of them
felt like a lot yes and it would be if
like they didn't just dominate games now
we are going to be talking about breast
of the wild a little bit and I think
breath of the wild would be a breath of
fresh air Legend of Zelda person to make
that joke Mike I'm not I know anyway um
yeah so if you're watching this on
youtube or gamespot let us know in the
comments and whatnot we're still reading
the chat but let us know what you want
in shadow of war details are kind of
sparse we're gonna see gameplan march
ace before we might see more stuff
leading up to its august release i'm
sure we will but yeah it's official
warner bros announced it target leaked
to the other day my job target thank you
you can watch the trailer itself on
games by right now you can check out
more from the game i think you should
play shadow of mordor if you have not
yet there are a lot of games coming up a
shadow of mordor is still a fantastic
game how long did it take place shadow
more 30 hours 30 i should say that's
good one hundred percent maybe go
outside like 40 to do this whole yeah
leszno you think
[Music]